[Music]
you are a very lucky girl
Miranda Wells will you marry me not many
men would be willing to take on somebody
with your baggage I mean three kids a
mountain of death
looking for Miranda Wells she's at work
right now you believe with me
Hummer son I'm afraid this comes with a
little bit of an explanation
hurricane warnings around weather guy
says it's gonna miss us but you never be
too careful no matter how bad things are
they can always get worse
mom I'm expecting a call from the bank
ray Johnson
Miranda Wells there goes my deductible
don't waste your insurance on this why
is he doing here bumper yet he's offered
to come over to fix it you're letting
him follow us home
youko now you're looking for her and she
runs into you it's pretty weird is it
your thoughts attract things with a
force that you cannot see but it's
definitely real okay this is me making
about pizza don't look at me have to be
careful Yeah right because we get what
we expect and open to the possibility
that whatever happens oh my god even the
bad stuff can lead to better things I
can't afford a new roof let me help
why are you helping me because I can
how do you know Miranda don't really why
are you fixing a roof I just don't want
you to bother this she doesn't love him
not like dad all your dad ever wanted
was for you to be happy how would you
know that
what are you doing right now taking in
this gorgeous sunset I don't understand
what's happening here I think you and I
collided for a reason
what's it say I've been dreaming it one
fun ball happen to the bumper karma or
maybe it's just a lousy driver
it's a better day coming
[Music]